So, sollte an sein.
Hallo Leute.
Hallo alle Channel-Camper, die skippt, ich hab nämlich heute schon wieder Comments im
Chat gesehen.
Moment, läuft's jetzt?
Ja, perfekt.
Ich muss jetzt mal gucken, ob man das Overlay sieht, is this called Overlay?
Hallo NG0.0?
NG0.0, ist klar, NG0.
Also das Discord-Overlay sieht man nicht, das ist aber ganz schön blöd.
Was ist da, wenn ich das hier jetzt einblende, seh ich's dann?
Überschreibt sich das nicht mit links?
Ah, ich guck grad mal.
Shadowplay?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Okay, man kann das aber in OBS hab ich gesehen, kann man irgendwo ein Häkchen machen, Capture
in Game Overlay und sowas, das geht.
Capture Third-Party Overlay, such as Steam, jetzt sieht man's, perfekt, jetzt sieht man's,
sehr schön.
Jetzt kann ich nur mal das Game einstellen.
Ja.
Oh, hab ich Titel und so geändert, Game Overwatch, Titel, wo sind die Mercy-Mains, wenn man sie
braucht?
Ja, das passt, oder?
Das passt nicht, dass es wieder so wird wie gestern.
Also heute müsste es von der Lautstärke auch ziemlich gut passen, Erx, und ich müsste
ungefähr gleich laut sein, ich hab jetzt sogar das Discord-Overlay am Start, dass man
sieht, wer was sagt und dass man nicht verwirrt ist, was da so viele Leute labern und so,
ich glaub das ist halt ganz gut.
Und jetzt erst mal ein, zwei Runden aufwärmen.
Brauchen wir das, auf dem Bank aufwärmen?
Ne, ne, ne, wir spielen gleich ranked, aber halt, aufwärmen.
Dann sitzen die Hooks auch wieder, es war die ersten zwei Runden gestern so, boah, nix
getroffen.
Scheiße.
Easy Wids.
Ich hab Deutsch installiert.
Was hast du?
Ich hab auf Deutsch installiert.
Boah.
Dann kannst du einfach umstellen in Settings.
Naja, ich mach grad.
Dann lädt er noch ein paar Gigabyte runter und dann ist gut.
Und ein paar MB, so groß.
Denen hat er die Language-Piles nicht.
Er könnte etwas lauter sein.
Echt?
Eigentlich, also laut dem Ausschlag im OBS, wenn er eher was sagt, wenn ich was sage,
ist das ungefähr gleich laut.
Ich könnte mich einfach einen Ticken leiser machen.
So, easy.
Ich kann dich noch einen Ticken lauter machen, das geht auch.
So, jetzt bist du noch ein bisschen lauter.
Wunderbar.
So, jetzt so müsste es aber passen, denke ich.
Du findest mich wenigstens lauter, gut, dann mach ich ihn noch einen Ticken lauter, das
sollte ja gehen.
Ich bin so froh, dass ich einen Mixer, also das Audio-Interface davor hab, wo ich noch
außerhalb von OBS ein bisschen Zeug regeln kann.
Hast du gerade das Wort mit W oder mit M angefangen?
Hä?
Was meinst du?
Dein Mixer?
Ich habe einen Mixer, ja, richtig, beziehungsweise ein Audio-Interface, ja, da muss man ja hier
die richtigen Fachbegriffe verwenden.
Ich hatte letztens einen in-game irgendwie, hatte so einen ultra bescheuerten Namen, wie
ich es denn dann irgendwie, wo ich dann immer aus dem Battlefield letztens irgendwie Vix-Mutt
oder so, das habe ich mir gedacht, Vix-Mutt ist down.
Magst nachher eine Runde StarCraft, StarCraft 1 habe ich mal gespielt, das ist aber schon
15 Jahre oder so her, nee, da, gibt es noch was neues StarCraft-technisch?
Forever, nex, ich gucke mal, ob das Mutant funktioniert.
Ja, Mutant funktioniert, da labere ich den E-AX nicht voll, wenn ich mit dem Chat rede.
Ja, oben links ist das Discord-Interface, ja, genau, das ist jetzt neu, das gab es vorher
auch schon, aber das in der Form ist jetzt neu, gab es heute Morgen ein Update in Discord.
Ist mittlerweile Free-To-Play StarCraft, ja, stimmt, so, ähm, ich invite dich mal, ne?
Warte, ich muss mal Mucke anmachen, baust du auch eine Playlist?
Ähm, nee, ich mache hier irgendwas an, ich glaube, ich mache erstmal ein bisschen zum
Warmen an, erstmal ohne Musik, so, ja, dann lass mal loslegen, was haben wir denn gestern
plus gemacht, so 180 circa?
Ja, wir haben gestern relativ viel gewonnen, ne, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 7-8 Games gewonnen,
3 verloren oder sowas, so aus dem Bauch raus, würde ich mal so sagen.
Mhm.
Na, mal gucken, also heute ist Master bestimmt, oder?
Easy Master, aber kein Ding.
Pass auf, jetzt kriegen wir erstmal die übelsten Flaschen schnellstellt, so, ich cue, erstmal
aufwärmen, erst mal Motivationsmusik anmachen, auf geht's, würdest du eigentlich, warte mal,
ich mute mich, wa?
Ähm, würdest du eigentlich auch für dein YouTube-Video StarCraft als Hintergrund-Gameplay
nehmen, äh, als Hintergrund-Gameplay, ähm, ist StarCraft so eine Sache, ich, wobei, warum
eigentlich, man wollte gerade sagen, man versteht halt nicht, was passiert, wenn man sich mit
dem Gameplay beschäftigt hat, ich gucke ja immerhin ab und zu mal ein paar Streams, also
weiß so grob, was abgeht, ich kann es ja überhaupt nicht einschätzen, richtig, außerdem sind
die meisten Leute übelst auf Shooter-Gameplay eingeschworen mittlerweile, endlich können
wir wieder gute Mercy-Gameplays genießen, euer, ich ahn es schon, wo sind die Mercy-Mains,
wenn man sie braucht, ja, alle Grandmasters, der gestern schon gesagt, ja, es war der Wahnsinn
gestern, mich hat das voll gewundert, wo sind die alle hin, ja, schlimm, sonst hast du dir
irgendwelche Mercy-Main-Grills, die immer am Start sind und gestern, alle Games, nix,
komisch, ganz, ganz merkwürdig, äh, ich könnte den Streamer auf Twitter pausen, hört mir
gerade ein, ja, ah, gepostet, wie einfach Twitter immer noch den falschen Titel für
meinen Stream hat, das haben die wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal gecashed vor 5 Tagen, hat
sie mir geupdatet, ähm, vielleicht ist Mercy den zu schwer, den er erstleunert, easy,
ah, easy, ich mach Speed, Speed, das ist, Lucio zum Einspielen ist wunderbar, da muss
man sich ein bisschen moveen und ich, und ich kanns aus, ich kanns aus dem Schlaf spielen,
ah, guck mal, wir haben ganz viele DPS, hier auf the Doooog, eh, wunderlich, dass wir
so viele DPS haben, DPS, gabs jemals ein Game, überleg mal ganz scharf, gabs irgendwo
ein Game, wo du mal ein Mangelware an DPS hattest, äh, ich hab kein Spiel gespielt,
das sowas, äh, ne, gibs nicht, ich hab, gibs nicht, ist, DPS ist immer genug, sogar
in MMOs, DPS hast du wie Sand am Meer, auch scheiß DPS, Heiler hast du auch noch recht
viel, aber Tanks hast du keine, du musst dir mal überlegen, also, es ist so Spiele wie
League of Legends, da kannst du dir ja mittlerweile deine Rolle auswählen, was du so sagst, da
hast du das Problem gar nicht, guck mal an, der Gegner, Moment, sag mal, kann das sein,
dass ich mit Single Support spiele grad, mit Lucio, haha, der Roadhog, wie er nix trifft,
ich lasse mal heal laufen bei euch, Killsteal, ach, geh mal on Spot, ok, die wollen nicht
geheilt werden, kommt keiner her, Harambe, ja, Yolo reingesprungen ist so, oh, wir haben
Orisa, halt mal jetzt erst auf, deswegen stehen wir hier wenigstens noch, noch ein bisschen,
jetzt können sein, dass wir backcapped werden, oh, rekt, nein, Sam Fischer schreibt das Spiel
auf, Battle Mercy, Battle Mercy, ich warte mal, ich warte mal auf euch, die Orisa, Yolo
Style, oder, wird nicht gewartet, geht direkt rein, ja, ja, er fliegt runter, oh nee, keiner
runtergefallen, puh, hahaha, die Dima, lol, na, ducken, spammen, wie die großen, das können
sie, komm Orisa, auf, Liner, das ist ja schlimm, will keiner rein, ich switch nächste Runde
mal auf Anna oder sowas, irgendwas mit ein bisschen mehr Heal, dachte, wenn wir das jetzt
ne Weile aussetzen, er barmt sich vielleicht einer mal Support zu spielen, oh mein Gott,
das war die beschissenste Pulsbombe, ich hab's gesehen, ich hab gleich wieder old, aber
die Koordination ist ja wieder absolut Killer, ein Spollsteiner retten den Junkrat, aber
der wollte nicht, ja, ich spiel Anna nächste Runde, das wird sonst nichts hier mit Lucio
Single Support, na, da geht was, da geht was, da geht was, am besten, die kommen jetzt
rechts rum, dann kann ich sie alle runterkicken, wahnsinnig, nice, der Roadhog muss gebasht
werden, er ist runtergetroppt, bzw. wird von unserer Orisa runtergezogen, war das ne Pulsbombe,
nice, schön ins Gesicht, Achtung, der kommt hinter dir, die flanken hinter dir rum, hinter
dir kommt ein McCree gleich, 90%, McCree pusht vorne raus, die pushen auf Spot, D.Va
weg, kommt her Leute, oh ne, fliegt McCree, easy win, easy win, easy clap, überhaupt
kein Problem, wir haben uns absichtlich so angestellt, wir wollen uns hier einspielen,
das heißt wir mussten uns das Leben ein bisschen schwer machen, Lucio Solo Heliometer, funktioniert,
General Slane, ich war gestern Nacht online bis irgendwie eins oder so, und jetzt wieder,
ja, ich hab Urlaub, nix damit switchen, wahrscheinlich hast du alles Gold und alle Gegner gekillt,
insofern, selbst wenn du nicht alles Gold hast, geht ja um die wichtigen Kills und nicht
um Hauptsache, ich hab hier die Hunde, 6 Pulsbomben, das spricht dafür, dass du nicht switchst,
sondern der McCree könnte switchen zum Beispiel, ich geh mal auf den Spot heilen, fuck, fuck,
die Urissa hat Fortify, die Durns angehabt, flieg, Laura, flieg, flieg, flieg, flieg,
ist der runtergefallen, nope, schade, unlock, ich geh drauf, also ich hab keinen Support,
ich hab die Pulsbombe geworfen, dann wurde ich gestunnt, dann war sie weg, und Ruhikult
auch, echt geil, der Lucio hat nimmer viel, auch jetzt wieder voll, eben das Todes, was,
Boquerino, Genji geht auf den Punkt, nice, der will nicht, dass ich ihn heile, ach gut,
haben wir keinen Bock drauf, wir haben überhaupt keine gescheiten Fights, ich krieg keine
Ulti, oh, oh, oh, oh, ich bin hier ganz schön, ganz schön weit vorne, ziemlich,
fuck, ich dachte, der stirbt jetzt, ich heb die Ulti auf, nein, der Chat sagt, das war
der, der Chat hat gerade gesagt, du sollst, ich nehm grad nix auf, du sollst mal Tracer
wie Zun spielen, das wollen die Leute jetzt sehen, und dann fällt er die Brücke runter,
ok, gleich, oh man, Leute, jetzt kann ich nicht mal gescheit holen, weil alle weg sind,
ich ulti bis jetzt, Mercy ist, hat geultet, innen drinnen, shit, oh, ich kann nix machen,
ist alles voll, sogar ein Reinhardt drinnen, der um sich swingt, aber 990, komm, ein Fight
noch, gewinnen und easy win, doch, LironDG, ich bin Diamant, ich hab auf mein Main Account
nicht mehr gespielt seit Season 3, deswegen hab ich mir extra einen neuen Account gemacht,
das ist kein Smurf im eigentlichen Sinne, oh, ich dachte, man kommt da rüber, ich wollte
es mal ausprobieren, ich hab grad voll gesrottet, also wenn ich jetzt verliert, ich war dran
schuld, ich wollte gucken, ob man über den Abgrund ohne Speedboost drüber kommt, ich
kann dir sagen, es funktioniert nicht, ich bin da, kommt raus, kommt raus, ich will euch
runterwerfen, nein, huge, huge Tire, was ne Runde ey, Lucio Solo heal, neues Meta,
es hat auch gepasst, in dem Moment, wo ich gesagt hab, das ist, was denn der, ja, ich
wollte jetzt auch irgendwas dummes im Chat schreiben, aber ich muss mich zurückhalten,
du weißt doch, wie das ist, wenn man streamt, da muss man Vorbild sein, dann siehst du,
ich bin gebannt, genau, danke für die Follows, ich hab den Follows halt ein bisschen leiser
gestellt, das heißt, es kann sein, dass ich es manchmal nicht mitkrieg, falls ich irgendwie
eine Donation verpasse, dann spam mich mal bitte voll, ey, das sollte nicht sein, zieh
es ja raus, ja, Vorbild von Twitch, neu, neue Season heute, huge, huge, schau mal, ich,
noch nicht ganz, noch nicht ganz, ich muss sagen, der Swerve kommt gerade echt gelegen,
so zum üben, aufwärmen, war das gut, weiß, ich muss ja sagen, bei mir ist es ja nicht
so wirklich, ich hab es so lange nicht gespielt, wenn ich mir überlegt hätte, ich würd jetzt
quasi Main Account spielen, quasi so Master und GM Games reinkommen, ey, nee, da hätt
ich echt keinen Affe drauf, vor allem wirst du als Mercy Main degradiert werden, vor allem
müsste ich wahrscheinlich, na, wobei, nee, in Grandmaster nicht, in Grandmaster gibt's
genug Mercys, Grandmaster gibt's genug Mercys, es ist anscheinend nur auf Diamond das Problem,
dass es keine Mercy Main gibt, ja, alle wollen so hoch, ne, alle wollen so klein, schrecklich,
hast ja schon wieder gesehen, keiner Support gespielt für die Runde, naja, das kann man
ja nicht blämen, wir hatten ein DPS und ein Support gespielt, easy, nee, wir konnten da
nix machen, Eichenwald, darf ich jetzt vielleicht mal Brautong spielen, ich guck mal, was die
anderen so am Start haben, McCree, Genji, 30 Stunden, quasi 30 Stunden Genji, wir haben
Mercy Main, Batlox, 12 Stunden, Mercy, Lucio Main, der darf Mercy spielen, ähm, was, ooooh,
was ist das hier, die Troll-Elo, der Torb, der Attack-Torb, die Flay, was, was ist da,
was ist da im Chat schon wieder los, wird das schon wieder getiltet, bevor die Runde
losgeht, seh ich das richtig, ja, ich spiel jetzt Ana, mal gucken, ob er das macht, ähm,
der trollt mit seinen komischen Armor Packs, also ich guck mal, wie's mit Ana geht, ansonsten
muss ich halt wieder die, Switch to Mercy, hey, er hat Mercy geswitcht, zu Metra Balls,
oh, wo ist der Schild hin, der Schild ist weg, dieses Gespanne, geht so auf den Sack,
komm Leute, lasst euch raushucken, Pokerino, oh, naja, man kann's ja mal probieren, ich
mach's, Schild kaputt, Schild weg, Mercy weg, glaub ich net, oh, ich kann da grad einen
wirklich durch, Soldier, Soldier ist weg, passt, also wenn wir jetzt noch ne Weile so
machen, dann haben wir die gleich, soweit ausgedümpft die Gegner, WTF, warum, warum stirbt
doch nix, so, genug gestorben oder nicht, ja, jetzt halt am Schluss nicht, vorher gut
und dann, fuck, alle tot von uns, Bad Company 3 halt, ja ich hoffe echt, es wird Bad Company
3, links ist ein Chunk her, ich guck mal ob ich den gehockt kriege, gleich Ulti, Schild
weg, scheiß Ulti, oh, heal, ich mach den so viel Damage gibt's doch net, ist ein bisschen
mies, dass keiner richtig reindrückt, ich hab die Symmetra auf mir drauf, fuck und ich
werd zugespammt, Symmetra ist tot, oben ist immer noch der Chunk her, die Mercy ist links,
oh, ich fliege, sag mal, oh Leute, was ist denn, warum geht denn da nix, warum geht hier
nix mit, das ist ja der Wahnsinn, geht nicht vorwärts, wir dürfen nicht zu schnell Climben,
das geht auch nicht, ich komm halt nicht durch hier gescheit, ah, perfekt, klasse, easy,
wenigstens Damage gemacht, ich könnt mir mal ein gescheites Fadenkreuz jetzt für Roadhog
einstellen, ich komm mal auf einer Schildtank picked, ja mach ich das, ähm, wie findest
du Moira, an sich find ich vom Konzept gut, dass du so nen Held hast, der quasi so ne
Ressource hat zum ausgeben und quasi dann mit durch Damage wieder, also quasi sowas
wie Mana hat, wenn man es so will bei Moira, ich hab grad mega den Unlucky, es tut ever
ab, glaubst du nicht, was denn Unlucky Hook, weißt du noch, dieses eine Video was ich dir
geschickt hab, mit diesem most impressive Roadhog Hook oder, ich kann, ne, kann ich
mich da mal dran erinnern, wo ich McCree gehooked hab und dann auf einmal Zenyatta hatte, das,
da war irgendwas, ja, genau das ist gerade mir auch passiert, also ich find Moira vom Konzept
her, um jetzt nochmal drauf zurück zu kommen, Chat find ich das gut, ich, mir fällt schwierig
Moira grad so ein bisschen in Combs zu sehen, ich mein Dallas hat probiert, auf Junkertown
mit ner Comp, die quasi darauf aufbaut mit Moira und sie haben gegen Bastion Strat einfach
nur auf den Sack gekriegt, du hast halt nur gewisse Anzahl von Helden, die für Close
Range Heal in Betracht kommen, so, also wenn jetzt sowas, wenn ich jetzt sowas wie Genji
Tracer und so spielst irgendwas, was du ein bisschen über Range heilen musst, das ist
schwierig mit Moira, aber wie gesagt, ich find das auch nicht besonders gut in dem Game,
deswegen, vielleicht findet ihr einer was Gutes und Moira ist übelst OP.
Doomfist, ey, dümmste Held aller Zeiten, die haben Symmetra, Attack Symmetra, der ist
fast tot, der Doomfist, alter, so jetzt ist Doomfist aber weg, ich muss mich heilen,
ne Frage, Symmetra, jetzt haben sie aber einen, jetzt haben sie nen Tele, pff, das ist wieder
lächerlich hier, was ist das für ne, für ne Rolle, weißt du was, nochmal Tarner Rang,
ähm, was haben wir, 3250 oder sowas, aber er hat noch übelst nen Trollkack dabei, oder,
next game, ich zieh uns mal raus, oder hast du irgendwas, was du gucken willst, ah, ich
bin zuversicht, dass wir immer erst da packen, es sei denn, das läuft so wie in diesem Game,
so, jetzt machen wir das Aufwärmen weg, jetzt haben wir uns aufgewärmt, win, loss, 0-0,
ne, eigentlich 1-1, oder, 1-1, 1-1 hatten wir, 1 gewonnen, 1 verloren, hallo, no second
player, das stimmt, die Bälle von Moira sind das einzige, was, was man als OP irgendwie
ansehen könnte, aber Moira hat allgemein Schwierigkeiten, gerade seinen Platz zu finden,
außer, dass jeder Moira spielt, ich, ich werd Schild picken, falls keiner Schild pickt,
was spielt dieser Gavars sonst, mercy, Gavars ist mercy main, jetzt, jetzt haben wir zwei
mercy mains, weißt du, ok, dann bleib ich doch mal rawtalk, ähm, Morris, ja, geb ich
dir recht, da geb ich dir voll und ganz recht, microhunts actions in bedcompany 3, wenn's
dann bedcompany 3 ist, brauchste, brauch keine, brauch keine Sau, ich find's ja schon grenzwertig,
wenn man diese, diese unlock packs hat, also sprich, dieses sniper unlock pack, bezahle
5€, hast alle sniper waffen, wir haben, wir haben 3 supports, ja, weil wir, weil wir den
mercy main haben, also wir haben 2 mercy mains und der mercy main spielt reinhardt, der andere
mercy main spielt mercy und der Rest möchte anscheinend gerne Symmetra und Moira spielen,
keine Ahnung, wo wir 3 supports haben, aber das geht, also man, auf dem Punkt ist das
jetzt, man, zwar nicht optimal, aber geht ja, sofern, sofern Moira und Symmetra auch noch
ein bisschen mitmeschen, was macht der reinhardt da in der ecke, keine Ahnung, da stehen, jebaten,
so voll in dieser areake feedet, ja, wo, wo wird geschnippsert, oben von der konne, oh
Gott, lass mich wieder alleine hier, help, wieso busht denn keiner, weiß net, die zarya
ist gut aufgeladen, sag mal, kann ich mal irgendeinen hook heute treffen, ich bin vorne mit dir,
ok, hook müssen wir nochmal üben heute, mercy, habse, hook müssen wir nochmal üben, ich
hab sagenhafte 0%, was heißt ich hab noch keinen hook getroffen, yeah, oh man, da darf
die zarya nicht so sehr feeden, wenn die da reingehen, werden sie, mercy, jawoll, rekt,
würde ich mal sagen, rekt, sniper, linke seite, wo ist er hin, knapp, knapp, ich hätt
ihn fast gehabt, der geht bestimmt wieder oben ans fenster, ich versuch guck, ob ich
ihn raushopen kann, you took, wo ist er, oben links, oben links ist er, ich guck mal, ob
er drunter geht, wenn er drunter geht, holen wir, er ist schon down, er ist down, stimmt
die symmetra, jetzt kommen sie mit ner fahrer an, bleib in der ulti, pass auf, pass auf,
pass auf
Ja, die D.Va ist noch links drinnen. Die können wir killen. Ich glaube die ist hochgegangen.
Er hat sich gesnimt.
Fuck! Choke! Er taugt. Ich hätte ihn killen können. Lucio geht links durch.
Wie sie hault. Was meinste Sam Fischer? Verstehe ich gerade nicht. Freut ihr euch auch schon auf 6 Uhr? Was ist denn um 6?
So in der letzten Zeit vor allem auf DPS. Das richtige Abstieg. Das war ich gerade so für McCree und der Rest ist alles so. Naja.
Das ist übrigens so. Ich merke es bei mir auch. Vor allem bei Roadhog. Ich setze nicht nur die Hooks oftmals daneben knapp, sondern auch die Follow-Up-Shots.
Da hast du was gehooked und denkst du musst du killen. Dann schießt es zweimal vorbei und es ist weg. Kacke. Aber wenn man ein bisschen Routine wieder kriegt, dann klappt das.
Ach das Winter-Wonderland-Update kommt heute. Das interessiert mich ehrlich gesagt nicht so großartig. Ich finde es sogar ein bisschen fragwürdig, Geschmackssache, ob es im ranked die Weihnachtsmaps überhaupt gespielt werden soll.
Weil sie sind halt schon anders von Belichtung her und Objekten und sowas. Es ist nicht wirklich ein riesen Unterschied. Kann man sich darüber streiten.
Anso, Bastion, D.Va, Eura. Bastion baut auf der rechten Seite auf. Wo da? Rechts hinter dem Kiosk. Hinter der Mauer oder bei uns da vorne irgendwo? Hinter der Mauer.
Hinter der Mauer. Ich mach einfach mal so blind. Ich hook mal so rechts in die Ecke. In der Hoffnung habe ich irgendwas. Mit der für 100 Zuschauer. Ich habe es nicht mal großartig auf YouTube gepostet und so.
Why? Wir wollen alle sehen wie wir Master werden heute. Uprank-Stream. Wobei noch ein paar Wins, ne? Dann. Und die haben zwei Sniper. Hanso? Und Vido.
Ne, rechts ist er. Ach da ist er. Ich gehe mal rechts durch. Bastion, linke Seite. Ich habe ihn gehooked. Ist down. Und Win. Was? Wo ist er? Aber trotzdem easy win.
Hello there.
Wettet einer 20 Euro, dass wir immer noch D.Va sind am Ende vom Stream. Na. Ich glaube das packen wir. Das kriegen wir hin.
Eiskäuter. Ich erinnere mich dran, wenn wir fertig sind. Da ging er ab.
Neues High gucken. Das gab ja fast nichts. Für dich gab es nichts. Ich habe schon wieder ein neues High. Das gab ja fast nichts. 14 Punkte oder so.
The fuck? Bei mir ca. 40. Hanso? Oder Leute wisst ihr ungefähr wie viel das gab? Oder vergucke ich mich jetzt? Wir hatten doch vorher noch eh. Ne. Ne. Warte mal. Ne. Vorher hatten wir 25. Ne. Vorher hatten wir 25.
Es gab jetzt 34 oder so. Ok. Ne. Gab doch mehr.
Ach ihr mit eurem Smurf gelaber. Für mich ist das kein Smurf. Neuer Account seitdem man 6 Monate nicht gespielt hat. Und vor allem wenn man sich anguckt was für kritische Sachen ich teilweise nicht treffe und scheiße stehe und kacke baue.
Also ich bin definitiv nicht da wo mein Main Account eingerankt ist. Deswegen spiele ich den ja auch nicht.
Ah geht. Solange wir keine 13 Minuten warten müssen. Manche englischen Streamer. Letzten Stream geguckt irgendwie auch da Estimate Time 45 und dann 13 Minuten rum.
Oh. Richtig gute Maps jetzt ne. Ich pick mal ganz schnell. Was können wir machen? Ich warte mal. Ich warte mal was die anderen picken. Was ist denn das?
Ok. Der Typ spielt. Hat 9 Stunden Bastion diese Season gespielt. Komm wir machen jetzt Bastion Strat. Aber das ist. Was gibt das wenn es fertig ist?
Das weiß ich noch nicht. Das würde uns überraschen. Ich warte noch mal kurz ab ja. Ich gehe mal in Voice rein was wir schwätzen. Wenn sie nerven gehe ich wieder raus.
Ich sehe es kommen dass ich Mercy spielen muss. Nee wir haben Mercy Main.
Das geht eigentlich. Die überlegen sich tatsächlich eine Taktik. Jetzt natürlich die Frage. Wir haben kein richtiges Schild für den Bastion. Entweder will der Payload Setup machen. Dann nehme ich einen Reinhardt. Oder ich nehme einen zweiten Support für Heal. Ich spiele mal Zen.
Kommen wir gucken wie gut das funktioniert. Je nachdem was die Gegner haben. Zen ist neben Lucian mein Lieblings Support.
Generell Zen ist übelst geil. Also wenn man was trifft was ich nach 6 Monaten nicht mehr wirklich mache. Aber gucken wir mal.
Zu viel Schild.
Ich muss kurz Deckung. Ja Harambe da kann ich dir nicht helfen.
Ich habe Schild gebaut. Ich mache den ganz gut. Damage gerade. Aber ich kann nicht wirklich weit vorne hin.
Oben ist ein McCree.
Ich verstecke mich mal. Weißt du.
Dass da nicht noch einer mit drauf schießt. Ich habe Ulti.
Warst du nicht mein Master. Doch bin ich ja noch. Also bin ich auf meinem Main Account. Aber habe ich seit 3 Monaten nicht gespielt.
Go go go. Bashing. Rechts rechts Junker da drinnen. Ich werde gebauen. Ich brauche ein Rätsel. Danke.
Wir gehen nach der Blicke.
Ich sehe auch gerade ich habe Frame Drops das Tod ist. Ich habe gleich wieder Ult.
McCree McCree McCree.
Ich habe die Mercy.
Was ist denn das? Das ist gar nichts. Das ist Soloreigirene. Ich habe gerade Performance Drops des Todes. Aber wissen geht nicht mehr.
Da ging wenig. Ist Internet technisch Telekom oder? Ich habe viel zu wenig FPS.
Also normalerweise halte ich 300 ohne Probleme. Du kannst ja nach der Runde mal neu starten.
Also irgendwie sind wir nicht durchgekommen. So überhaupt nicht. Weil wieder fast nichts umgekippt ist.
Wenn der Bastion hat vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt dazu beigetragen, dass es besser funktioniert hat.
Ja gucken wir mal. Hämmern. Wir hämmern. Falls einer mit Tank spielt. Kann doch sein, dass ich wieder alleine vorne stehe und sich keiner dafür interessiert.
Das ist der Wahnsinn. Was sagt denn deine FPS Anzeige? Der Drop von 200 runter auf 90.
Das ist nicht wirklich spielbar. Vor allem Aim technisch. Du triffst ja nichts gescheit.
Geht der Chat noch? Leute geht der Chat noch? Bei mir hat sich das seit 6 Minuten nichts getan im Chat.
Ich muss mal refreshen. Chat ist kaputt.
Geht noch. Ja jetzt gehts wieder.
200 Xbox. Es gibt mir langsam auch voll auf den Sack so was. Ich hab ständig Probleme.
Der Junker trifft gar nicht richtig. Ich geh mal mit unserem Harambe da runter.
Okay. Da muss der Bastion schon selbst klar kommen.
Wir sind ein bisschen verteilt. Die sind über uns. Okay wir sollten jetzt mal. Ich brauch Heal.
Mega verteilt. Ich hab gleich ein Shatter. War nix. Huge Shatter war das. Huge Shatter.
Absolut Huge Shatter. Fat Big Slam.
Ich seh das Schlimmste. Leute nicht sterben. Ich setz euch Heal hin.
Was die fast tot hätten.
Oh nee. Puh. Wir müssen ein Paylord ran.
Schleierweiser. Vielleicht kriegen wir das noch ein bisschen gestalt.
Was? Nein ich war doch dran. Sieh nein. Sieh nein.
Das hätten wir so gehalten können. Willst du neu starten? Bis gleich. So Leute hauen wir ne Runde Musik an.
Das kann man dann hier mal anmachen. Geh gleich weiter. Ich hoffe die Telekom kackt heute nicht wieder ab.
Das haben ganz viele Leute wenn man im Internet guckt zu den gleichen Problemen. Es ist nicht die 24 Stunden Trennung die es früher bei DSL gab.
Das kommt meistens um 18 Uhr vor und ein bisschen nach.
Passend zum Stream.
Die Leute verschrecken.
Ich mein ich bin Frankfurter. Muss Haftbefehl.
Louis Vuitton Store. Fick auf Sponsor.
Max hat auch seine negativen Seiten.
Er kracht keine Ahnung. Ich find es ganz lustig.
Louis Vuitton Store.
Haftbefehl aus Nudebox.
Louis Vuitton Store
Louis Vuitton Store.